hello everyone welcome to part three of
my resident evil village playthrough i
think i have fixed my brightness
settings
i had to basically lie to it completely
like the settings are just way off but i
think we can see a little bit better now
um so i just got into the castle just
saved right here
we've been introduced to a whole lot of
crazy characters
um there's some
a hole for something spherical hmm
probably not the family photo
craftsman okay the late 19th century
norsten was branded a heretic in his
homeland he wanted the village lands
until he settled in a remote village
created four labyrinths the castle the
house on a hill the water wheel and the
iron tower
wow and then he killed himself
each labyrinth is unique and requires
its own specially crafted metal ball to
operate
each one contains crystallized human
remains
okay well that's some [ __ ] but i imagine
that's supposed to be this causal
that's interesting okay in the demo
the uh the vendor was here i think
maybe he'll be back in a safe room later
okay
the game is still pretty dark but it is
better i also actually um
turned retracing on because the
there's no way this opens right no let's
go this way close the um
series x says ray tracing okay
let's go hang on is this a hub this is a
plant i can take no let's go upstairs
oh buddy
don't do that either i don't have
anything spherical there do i what's
what these plates are gonna turn into
something
i think i already tried this
oh no
[Laughter]
oh yes hot though you know
like it's sort of great for me
if we're being honest and there's three
of them and they're like twins
oh jesus
[Laughter]
fun ride though it's a nice way to call
so thank you you guys are really nice
hosts
[Music]
okay mother i bring you fresh prey
you are so kind to me daughters hello
ah now let's take a look at him
wow well ethan winters
you escaped my little brother's idiot
games did you
you're related can you do that like
[ __ ] that he did too then
i'm super special i'm so special oh no
oh
you'll have to take my clothes off to
find out how special i am oh what a
shame for everyone involved
oh this is the bit ugh
we're starting to go a little stale then
let's devour his man flesh quickly
mother i am the one who captured him
now now daughters first i must inform
mother miranda
they knew what they were doing they knew
before
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's not so bad actually
let's defend over to get through the
doors of our own castle
you're all hot but this sucks a bit and
i'm in pain
okay um
i'm worried it's going to make me swing
it doesn't feel like i can
he's just really
oh buddy oh just
what we're doing to this man's hands
oh yeah that'll fix it yeah that'll um
that'll yeah it'll be fine also my green
screen is having a lot of trouble with
this
minimize it as much as i can
there we go i tried to do it without
lights on this time because it's
spookier that way
um but it does mean you'll see green
screen static in any case
okay um hmm
i'm surprised that i can't do anything
with this yet maybe i'll be able to
eventually
we did also just pick up a crimson gloss
i wonder if it has anything i can
examine
it doesn't look like it and i never
looked at the crystal skull but i think
this is just to be sold
it's pretty cool i would cute that as an
art piece
um there's this australian movie called
wolf creek or at least i think it's set
in australia
where the same thing happens where like
people get
like nails through their hands and hand
stuff just really gets me and maybe it's
because i recently can still kind of see
where it's pink there as a scar
i got in a an accident and i messed my
hands up
and couldn't use them for a number of
weeks and it was awful and disgusting
but i'm like um
well these idiots also just keep leaving
me places
it's really stupid i think we probably
just gotta walk out here i think i found
everything
game is still pretty dark
but in snails and it's the atmosphere
you keep saying that but then how do i
do it
um oh you've been drinking
blood tea out here it is man blood which
you apparently love
okay anything anything at all
any items maidens of the harvest
everybody cute um all right
it's gonna be a no oh okay didn't expect
that
it's my own footsteps i thought it was
somebody else's
how about here aha
okay
look at that ray tracing look at it go
beautiful
okay i don't love the look of this area
not a huge fan
um
okay i feel like did this maybe was this
maybe the area that we were in
in the second demo
i'm not positive though um
but obviously this castle's pretty big i
think it was
this is gonna be locked oh
oh that wasn't locked
oh that was a shadow oh
okay um well
i didn't love that
i'll take the gunpowder why do they even
have gunpowder what do you vampire women
doing with gunpowder
locked oh [ __ ]
okay i just went full loop i did i don't
know why
door's unlocking is making me nervous
there's nothing else in here no okay
she's not a huge fan of
of the creepy shadow is um
sort of the problem i'm having with this
main hole out here
i can't fluid i will take i'm having a
weird trouble
with picking stuff up you have to be
looking at it the exact right way
um
okay
we don't need it right now but good to
craft it uh what is this shiny thing
here
is that anything no
just reflections i don't want to walk
out this door at all
it's you know i've never wanted to walk
out a door less than i do right now
okay where have they taken rows
the shadow is just one of these okay
that's fine that's fine
so these were the things on the floor
before
you're going to need three for that one
that what does it say hang on
the angel of anger looks down in rage
from on high
hot the angel of happiness is vicious
visage looks on words of wisdom by her
side
the angel of pleasure appreciates art
best kept behind a gilded door
and this is a lot of things the angel of
sadness weeps alone in a deep dark place
that's me tag yourself i'm the angel of
sadness weeping alone in a deep dark
place
[Laughter]
um okay i hate everything
i'm going to just get this out of here
now so that i don't screw myself later
there we go great
and i wonder if he's back in here or am
i just procrastinating at this point
he is in here hello my friend oh
we meet again good day duke why are you
here
where there's coin to be made
and have you found your daughter no no
if she is truly here the lady of the
castle would have kept little rose in
her private chambers
would she not i wouldn't have that baby
cries like a [ __ ]
i'll keep that baby why don't you take
it upstairs in that dark room by itself
get lucky
and speaking of looking here to make a
purchase
i mean let's take a look make a purchase
i'm gonna sell
my skull
i could also sell that right i'm not
going to yet just in case
we'll sell that little and often fills
the purse
as they say and i think we probably want
to
upgrade the handgun realistically
okay which of these i can't afford that
so i can't afford any of it
excellent okay i'm trying to figure out
if i should save or if i should
i think we'll leave it for now buy some
ammo
thank you for your purchase buy some of
this too
nah i'm just we'll come back here and
figure it out if i die or whatever i
think right now we're just gonna i would
like to save for the upgrades
good day sir
okay
up we go okay i remember this area
from the demo for sure but the problem
is i don't remember exactly what
happened
in the demos i think somebody came into
here but i'm not positive
um
i hate it every time i'm disappointed by
a door opening
give me less options man just cut me off
from everywhere it's comforting
okay great that's good we love that for
us
great so many boots so many boots
um well [ __ ]
i'm gonna go this way
okay okay
did i does that me did i did i do that
opened uh
okay cool
this is a loop this is where i was
before
i've been here okay i'm just actually
opening loops for myself
okay that's good we love that for me
i'm actually comfortable with that
entirely let's go upstairs
the sounds man it's a lot like resident
evil 4.
i feel like resident evil 4 had a ton of
just
sounds
okay
i know she shows up here somewhere
[ __ ] i know she does
but it's not lady d it's one of the
daughters
just go look through
everything oh
all right that that i don't actually
feel good about that i feel like i just
probably broke something historic
okay i'll unlock that later presumably
can i break this too
didn't care about that one i probably
should though
i'm out here trying to craft stuff
oh okay you're invincible are you caesar
you jerk
this room i also sort of remember
there's something about like a wine she
likes
yep yep okay cool
there was something to get in here
though too i know that much
um you probably need a bottle
which i don't have yet
okay and then that's gonna like open
that as a door or something maybe
i don't know all right
this way
[ __ ] door's closing it's just so rude
i'm really not a fan okay that's where
i've gotta go
let's do this first
love herbs i think i can craft now
actually
yes beautiful all right
put the eye in whoever did this to you i
don't know why they'd be doing that to
their own house
you think it was funny it was messed up
somebody literally just put blood on her
eye
um okay yeah cool hello my
and friend i just gotta run
oh wait his hand fully healed
because of the chem fluid really
okay let me string you up
now no just watch i'm okay thank you
neither preferably i'd prefer neither
which [ __ ] i know down here is not
ideal either for that
um so many bullets though wait did i
really i don't have
any oh i probably should have bought
some
mistakes were made i'm just trying to
upgrade my gun you know what i'm saying
the dollar made the mistake from stanley
slash that face with a knife that at
night i can hear wailings of ghost room
holes i don't know what to do the young
ladies were complaining it was too hot
and stuffy during dinner so i opened the
window just to crack shut it shut it now
they all streaked me and used and i fear
i may be taken down into the cellar
never to be seen again
that's interesting they can't do
something with the outdoors
curious maybe they're stuck in this
castle for some reason
hmm
okay
great
hello what are you doing
i don't know if she can see me she can't
that's totally triggered she has to walk
away
honestly not even just talking about how
big the tibies are she ha she has to
have back problems
why you haven't had these doors remade
or just removed entirely
like that's just plaster you could
i'm concerned i'm just concerned about
your back
i would like to see you hello let me
through please
um okay something i could grab on here i
think right
i think i think i think i think i think
uh i will take mohancon ammo this is
like the most well equipped i've ever
been in any resident evil game ever
i know it's not going to go well as soon
as i go down here
but we'll try it
[Music]
all right everybody's just leaving money
around in boxes that they fully sealed
for some reason
um here we go so obviously again i know
this from the demo
i'm excited to get to a part that's um
absolutely not in the demo though which
probably isn't that far away should i
put the knife away like just put
everything away just go
and then punch it i can't over here
yeah you got it you got to be lighting
things
come on buddy there you go this first
one we'll get you over to the second one
yeah you're cool
beautiful
sorry what there we go that was very
dark
okay um
i know there are a bunch of enemies down
here i know they're
uh what is this what is this do you
think what
i don't know i'm sort of into it um okay
nothing
it's so quiet if
this [ __ ] sound design in this game
is
so good
and a lot of it doesn't mean anything
which is how it gets you
i love it um
oh my god that's awful
oh it's just a lot of just
an excessive amount of torture
it's just why you don't
is you don't have to go that hard on the
torch i think the enemy starts showing
up around here
okay
so it's experiments right
suspiciously clean bowl hmm what are you
doing out here buddy
okay okay okay
no that was me though oh really alert at
times classic
ingrid right you know just [ __ ] chill
out
on how alert you are ingrid it's that
kind of instability we don't
[ __ ] [ __ ] it was also at the devil
and it scared me anyway
okay cool great i'm having a great time
[ __ ] so stacked though
all right start [ __ ] showing up then
you [ __ ] [ __ ] come on
is it just him though or are they coming
from behind me as well because if they
are i feel like i should be concerned
about that oh hello oh my
okay so
nope bad
these guys just don't go down do they
you just really
you're just you're just very up aren't
you you're just really [ __ ]
up and at them at least they're slow and
also i can do this because i have so
much ammo
but i don't know if they oh [ __ ] they
were everywhere but i don't know if they
keep spawning
here's the problem
[ __ ] off man just [ __ ] just [ __ ] the
[ __ ] off dude
just oh sick money all right well i can
still hear you
oh [ __ ]
the brightness is the biggest problem
that i'm having here
stay down punk
it's just a lot of shots it's six
oh well we'd love to see that um okay
wait wait wait wait i caught i can't go
through there oh [ __ ] [ __ ] somebody's
gonna show up
somebody's gonna shut up i really should
remember
but they don't okay cool
great
out of the ground like how are you gonna
just spawn wherever you want to
[Applause]
oh my god please don't come from behind
me as well
being wasteful but i do feel all right
with it cool sword dude that was
actually oh
oh i thought you dropped the swords out
though you're gonna go down
[ __ ] sake please just oh my god
ingrid's necklace uh-huh that's another
skull
okay yeah i hear things i'm aware that
things are audibly happening oh god
i will say to anyone playing on console
i actually think it's an xbox specific
issue people were saying
um i turned off some of the the settings
that i was having issue with
where uh there was like a fake um
latency basically uh for some reason
so it's now significantly easier to aim
i'm gonna assess
even though i am doing it very
sporadically it is easier now um
is there anything to do with this
no
just gotta sell it
okay cool
i don't think i can open this can i
negative
okay can go this way which we're going
to do can't believe cassandra caused
all this mess can't believe you
won't [ __ ] leave me alone also who's
cassandra should i know who that is
a healthy man's blood
i can't wait sucky
does she know that she's like kind of
turning me on like is she aware that
squeeze the blood out when they're alive
isn't it like
much do you think she knows who she's
going little one that it's all like very
seductive
you know what are you squeezing out
your bullets cannot harm
so you stupid man
thing i'm gonna stop saying that to all
my friends
stupid man thing okay am i supposed to
shoot you that's the problem is i don't
know if i'm supposed to shoot you
can i shoot that though we can shoot
that
like are you but or are you invincible i
still am just not really sure
oh my god i ran out of ammo oh i spoke
way too soon i thought that i was really
fine and gonna be fine
i really thought i was way better off
than i actually am oh my health is fine
oh okay
i feel no pain yeah it does seem like
i'm not supposed to shoot it
i'm gonna just put that out there it
does seem like it's not going to do
anything
this can't be but then why is it giving
me all the ammo you know
oh i wish i could dodge in some way
he's having a bad day he's just not
having a good time
uh okay i'm just gonna take some of that
who's gonna take it
you get uh oh no i'm not trying to craft
it sorry i'm trying to use it
hang on just let me fix my shitty hands
i'll slice your throat and stuff it with
water
i still think this is probably not the
right call and then i need to run
but i'm just not certain
i don't think they can be killed i
really don't think they can be killed
well now i'm cornered though so
it was probably just telling me that i
don't have a lot of ammo because
because i ran out right where do i go
get away from me get away from me
can you leave please um okay
is there a way through this door no is
there is something i can do with this
also no sure
yeah me too dude leave me alone then
he's calming on a timer surely
oh oh oh okay
she could be harmed
oh i must have just been like a second
whoa that's cool what
damn okay that makes sense i just wasn't
sure
okay great um brilliant that opened
i'm stoked about this crystal torso
situation
it's cool as hell all right i'd keep
that art in my house
really did waste all my ammo because i
was overconfident though so
that's the thing that's occurred aha
this is going to be the wine that goes
on that mantle
[Music]
that hand that hand it's just
she's really having a tough time out
here man
okay
i'm gonna go back to the knife for now
um
okay i don't
recognize this area let's check
everything
recoil compensator
sweet
it's gonna be here probably
awesome great stuffed about that
okay uh that's where we came from
oh there's a lockpick okay
come back here and do this
with the lockpick
thank you for the achievements my gosh
is that a thing i need
or is it also sellable okay um i should
figure out my inventory this is a mess
right now
i'll just maybe move all my weapons over
to this side
just for tidiness
white bum can go here and we'll put all
the
medicine down here okay cool
all right i feel like i recognize this
room too that's where
lady deposted through there in that
first demo i think
i can never tell if it's me walking or
ethan walking
okay i don't think there's anything for
me to grab in here right now there was
there wasn't that first emma but they
seem to have changed
things okay cool can't wait let's go
it's gonna be great okay uh
that wine room
i think is upstairs
um merchant's room
kitchen
[Music]
dining room i could do that
uh which one is it that's why you want
me to go right now
i might go to the dining room just to
quit yet key oh that's the key that's
needed that okay
um hmm
that's what i kind of meant was maybe i
go back up there to the to that long pic
well let's just keep going shall we
this is where it wants me to go right
now
for whatever reason
see how i could do no i just don't think
i'm ready for that yet
um hey man i had a rough time out there
i'd love to it was not great for me i
made some mistakes
i wasn't sure if she could die and i was
wasteful
so let's sell this and i like it though
but no what's it gonna do sell that
sell that sell that keep that
okay
and buy it i will what was it maybe i
should inspect them first but what's it
really gonna do
oh dude i'm rich now okay
all the handgun ammos
i saw you eyeing that i still want these
upgrades more than anything
okay um
ammo capacity would be helpful power i
feel like is probably the most helpful
yeah do that one
this simple modification can be done in
just a moment
i can afford all of them so let's just
do all of them
and i will do the shotgun
a bit later um
thank you for your purchase as well
and then leave it there for now i should
have done that
probably should have done that didn't
check it's fine okay i feel all right
good day then good day let me save
yes okay
back out we go
upstairs oh
this was the loop back this way yeah
okay i'm getting orientated
it does feel like like resident evil 4
in a whole bunch of ways
this is the wine room correct
so okay gonna put the wine in here
you love to see it just get the gun out
just in case
is everything reloaded yeah we're all
right
okay
i could craft more ammo too um okay it's
gonna be a key probably
courtyard key
i don't think this is going to be that
easy i don't buy this
for a [ __ ] second
key if you say so
i'm also not actually trying to leave
though am i like
i'm trying to get my kid
so why would i
leave still locked
there's nothing this way back downstairs
all right
hello there's nothing i can do about you
right now
okay yep good
great let's go i got out
okay cool all right well we did it we
finished the game everything's fine
everybody
this is beautiful though
she wasn't gonna die because i hadn't
opened the windows you know what i'm
saying there's no point
sweet all right i should do some
crafting
yes yes yes
okay
this is beautiful what is the you know
it's a nice day for a white wedding
okay that door looks ominous
i'm just gonna look around first i don't
like that one either
no they're all bad this one's probably
the worst of the bunch [ __ ] that door
i've never seen a shitty adore in my
life and i don't care who he is it
oh god what's the noise oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god okay
which door do we go for
i think we're gonna go with this one
because like
you look sort of nice it's locked
okay hell door it is
is she just
completely oblivious to everything going
on or is
or am i being baited
because it's working yes i will follow
thank you
that is dark
[Music]
this does seem more in line with where i
want to be though again
i don't feel like i want to leave yet i
am looking for mia
who is also like because of everything
that happened with my stupid very dead
probably not dead wife
almost definitely problematic like i bet
that baby
is going to turn into some tense
tentacle monster i always said tenster
um and it's gonna be a bad time for
everybody what
have you done to my daughter nothing
just i just sort of like turned her into
a skull and then
um a crystallized skull and then sold it
so that i could buy
um
it's me accidentally hitting that door
um so i could buy a handgun
america we can all agree on that i think
uh you understand
you were also have an american accent
for no
obvious reason great
surprise the main hall hasn't been fully
explored but i
i'm sure what um
what's this uh we would like to find out
more about that
so that would be cool
okay
he's going to kill me i don't like this
hmm i don't know what it is but
something about the vibe in here is
is off the vibe the vibe's bad
um yep okay
women are blind to male advances but the
poor shall take their chances to give
their lord
their bounty zones so that soon the wine
may flow
is this a puzzle like about a woman
being blind
to the maybe i'm overthinking it one
step at a time
i kind of want to go into the water but
i don't know if that's a good idea for
you ethan but we're gonna try it
cool hot tub nice hell yeah you wanna
you wanna come in where where'd you go
you upset about your daughter we could
talk about it in the hot tub
that would be probably like super
relaxing for you
okay well i'm now dripping in blood
which probably helps
probably she's probably gonna
not detect that [ __ ] still so dark
okay my favorite part of resident evil
eight is it me moving or is it you
great
where have you gone madam
there probably is something in here can
i move these
nope fell in the water it's fine
okay it is about that but i can only
move him
no we can move all of them or can we not
move the women
can all be moved okay
got it
um women are blind to male advances but
the poor shall take their chances to
give their lord their bounty
zone so that soon the wine may flow got
it we're gonna make the wine
flow
it makes me think the women should be
facing each other
i suspect
give it a shot or at least the women
aren't facing any men
right but if i were to guess who the
poor was
it would probably be them not definitely
not her
and that's maybe a lord i'm not really
sure
the porsche will take the chances to
give their lord that bounty sun
i mean i'm gonna try and maybe maybe we
move him
this way
oh okay yeah was pretty literal cool
great cool
where did she go
that's fine that's fine
okay ah
get get dead what also yeah if you guys
hear background noise it's because you
know
there's another person in this apartment
i understand that that's confusing
um
this is what you're confused about ethan
this of all things
i don't know dude i think that this is
actually comparatively pretty chill
compared to some of the other [ __ ] we've
been through
i think this is a little blood cellar is
actually sort of self-explanatory
those steps worked
okay wait what's that
i can't get there yet okay
i didn't like that if i'm being honest i
thought that that actually looked pretty
[ __ ]
can i break these then the music cut i'm
gonna get a [ __ ] jump scare any
minute now i tell you
you shouldn't put yellow looking things
on things that can't be broken
that's all i'm gonna say
that's confusing design
okay did i just walk over a body there
then
or all right okay music okay
sounds oh my god
that's why the sounds were happening
six it is six and then is this
[ __ ] gonna get up
[ __ ] and i've learned from the first
time that i have been wasteful with ammo
that i'm not the [ __ ] hot shot that i
think i am
three four so it's four if it's closer
to the head
still a lot of shots anybody else in
here though
anybody else trying to [ __ ] around and
get killed
or where from where from whence
have you spawned i haven't seen you so
there you are buddy where you go
where you going nope
oh my gosh okay
i don't need to do that right now i'm
okay
i'll say can't gun am i i don't even
really need to do that at all i don't
think
i'm probably wrong it's probably the
game's gonna surprise me again isn't it
i'm gonna be super wrong about
this [ __ ] false sense of security i
have right now
that was a waste of ammo it's okay it's
fine
everything's fine we're doing great down
here
we're getting ammo
making it happen having a great time in
this weird [ __ ]
blood orgy prison oh jesus i don't love
that oh god
how were the people in this town ever
okay like they told these stories when
we met them earlier about how they used
to be fine
oh my god son of a [ __ ]
okay it's cool oh
i tend so hot i just gave myself a cramp
in the whole leg
jesus um all right
no it's fine i maintain that everything
is fine
okay okay
uh yeah when we were talking to the
townspoke they were like everything was
fine
under mother miranda until the lycan
showed up and i'm like you have this
[ __ ] castle up here this whole time
with these
very large aggressive crazy [ __ ]
talking about how they need fresh
man blood i feel like maybe you weren't
all fine
i feel like maybe some of you is this is
this
the fault of modern feminism that just
the men were being taken but nobody
cared
you know there's when will when will the
feminists stop then you know
they just there's no end to it they just
don't care about the men
what's your plan oh he did crawl through
i didn't think he'd be able to do that
i'm impressed
up too far nope that was my fault i got
stuck on something
this music's very dramatic
we seem to be okay i'm gonna do some
crafting
yes yes good okay
excellent um all right we gotta keep
moving
and they are going to keep spawning and
they are going to keep scaring me
as much as i seem like i'm fine it's
it's it's fraudulent this like the way
this is set up just really making me
think of um
texas chainsaw massacre the way it's
also like
the wooden planks in the hallways and
the
anyway okay
hey buddy hello i know you think the
higher ground is good and all but it
actually makes going for your face a
fair bit easier
thank you for the money you're all
[ __ ] loaded down here and it's great
uh oh
oh i didn't think that would do that
well isn't that a stock contrast to what
i was just [ __ ] looking at
it was like a vacation it's like
is that the place where i ended in i
think i've been down there um okay this
is wonderful great i love it this
i actually am just happy super happy to
be here
at all times trying to find a very tall
thick woman
maybe make my dreams come true i frankly
don't mind becoming a vampire we can
retire here together that would be great
actually in if anything i would prefer
it
to like returning to my stupid crying
child
and my very shot up wife so you know
there's that we're gonna leave this here
everyone
uh i will see you all part four should
be up tomorrow